oh boy
what's up guys i am so excited because
the samsung event just ended well today
depending upon when you're watching this
which means my friends we have new
devices in hand i would say in studio
but i'm actually in my sister's basement
because i'm on the east coast right now
i am so excited about this because i
obviously love testing out new phones
and today we have got the samsung galaxy
s 22 plus and the brand new samsung
galaxy s22 ultra i'm gonna put some
links in the description if you guys
want to get any of the films that i'm
talking about today these are affiliate
links so if you do use those just know
that you are helping me out and my
channel you might hear some stomping
feet upstairs that is the sound of a
two-year-old just making her way around
the house so the first thing that we're
gonna unbox is the samsung galaxy s 22
plus there are two versions of this
there's the s22 plus which is the larger
display and the s22 which is a little
bit smaller of a display so this one
we're gonna open first because this is
the gold pink color and when i saw this
during the announcement i was like oh
beautiful so let's see what it looks
like in person so here's the unboxing
it's very it's very simple now that
nothing really comes in the boxes
anymore it's like basically like here's
a phone good luck have fun oh we do have
sim card ejector which is quite a treat
wow this color is really
really pretty so like i said there are
two versions of the s22 the s22 and the
s22 plus they both have an internal
storage option of 128 and 256 gigs both
running snapdragon 8 gen 1 both with 8
gigs of ram they each have three rear
cameras a 50 megapixel wide a 12
megapixel ultra wide a 10 megapixel
telephoto with 3x optical zoom and the
front-facing camera is 10 megapixels a
smaller s22 has a 3700 milliamp hour
battery with a 6.1 inch display whereas
the s22 plus has a 4500 milliamp hour
battery and a 6.6 inch display these
come in the phantom black phantom white
green pink gold and there are some
samsung exclusive colors graphite cream
sky blue and violet i think this pink
gold might be my favorite are we
surprised no we're not since we're doing
an unboxing we might as well see what
we've gotten here we've got usbc to usbc
cable and a lovely little piece of paper
where's my ultra where's the ultra how
is this an unboxing with no lid what
have i done oh gosh okay well the lid
has fallen off so no it's not the lid
this is the bottom of the box
so i don't know which color this one is
but we're gonna find out
oh it's a fan in black
look at that okay we gotta take this
sticker off
okay we got a front sticker too ready
front sticker front sticker
get into it
so satisfying it's actually so strange
going from the s21 ultra because the s21
had such a huge camera bump whereas this
it's just like the lenses are kind of
popping up so there's no actual bump on
the s22 so you guys can see like it's
crazy because it's like it's not there i
think i like it i'm not really sure i'm
kind of i'm a little indifferent about
it did like the camera bump because it
really did sort of set it apart and it
kind of separated from the phone maybe i
do like this more i'm not sure i'll get
back to you in the full review i do like
that it's all very seamless so it feels
very very clean so the s22 ultra has a
6.8 inch edge qhd plus dynamic amoled 2x
display with a refresh rate between 1
and 120 hertz it has four rear cameras
there's an ultra wide a wide two
telephoto lenses and a front-facing 40
megapixel camera it has a 5 000 milliamp
battery life and there's four colors
that you can choose from there's fan in
black white green and burgundy they do
have some online exclusive colors
there's a graphite a red and the sky
blue that one's actually it's pretty
nice one thing that i'm most excited to
test out on this is the night ography so
this is a new feature where of course
it's using ai i feel like the ai
buzzwords there's this two words
artificial intelligence do you know what
i mean it has been tossed around so much
over the past couple of years like what
does that actually mean well in this
case in the presentation they were
showing how it takes a bunch of photos
and then it goes in and determines which
photos look the best if there's some
blurry or shaky ones those are then
removed and then all of those photos are
kind of merged together to make one
solid still and crisp image that's gonna
be something that is definitely high on
the list to test off test out tap who's
reading this which is how to power off
your phone i can't do two things at once
i don't i just it's impossible the thing
that i'm excited to test out is in their
portrait videography portrait photo for
video you can now kind of shift the
focus and that's going to be kind of
interesting and i feel like that's kind
of rivaling the iphone 13s cinematic
mode which i'm not going to lie to you
i don't think i've ever used since i did
my review of the iphone now that i'm
thinking about it they've also improved
the portrait mode they also showed this
really cool demo of i know for a fact
that if any of you have ever used
portrait mode if you're holding
something or it's like the example that
they showed was this girl had a straw on
her drink then the straw goes out of
focus or whatever you're holding kind of
goes out of focus so with this it's
being able to detect what should
actually be in focus like if you're
holding something that is a part of the
image that is a part of your body right
now that should stay in focus so i'm
very excited to also test that out i
feel like there's so many small little
updates that may seem kind of
insignificant but in the grand scheme of
things like these small little updates
to video and photo are actually a pretty
big deal another thing is the new s pen
so this new s pen is supposed to have 70
improved accuracy over the s21 which is
kind of exciting because it really is so
interesting like trying to use these
pens and then having them not be as
responsive as possible and i think
samsung has actually done a pretty good
job with that so i'm
adding to the list another thing that
justine is excited to try out on the new
devices so here they are
both next to each other the s22
definitely has a much more rounded kind
of look where the s22 ultra kind of is a
little more boxy with this new s22 ultra
and of course the advancements in the s
pen this has a very notice feel i mean
this basically feels like a note but
it's not a note but it might as well be
a note like what is a note i don't even
know anymore if you guys haven't already
be sure to subscribe because i'm going
to be doing a follow-up review on both
of these devices they may be in one
single video they may be in separate
videos let me know what you guys would
prefer and if you're interested in
getting any of these devices again i put
some affiliate links in the description
below so be sure to go check those out
if you are looking to get one of these
devices and with that my friends i will
see you in the next video
the samsung galaxy
s22 ultra
do you want to show them the other phone
look hold it up here that's jesse hold
up show him
there you go nice nice good job keep
holding it up
there you go nice
yeah no it's jessie's that's not keep
holding it up you gotta show it to him
okay